eh
bien
bon plateau est beau plateau très
familiale du fils de lan
qu'est-ce qui les boutons fils puis
quand on pense que j'appelle ça avec ma
[ __ ]
il est très bon on va parler de lui
c'est le warm up
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir benjamin
benjamin ma fille tu es devenu une star
des réseaux sociaux en piégeant ton père
dans un canular
organisé par tom villa en regard
aux pc d'appeler cette personne enfin
s'il vous plaît en régie
alors oui bonjour monsieur c'est
concernant la petite annonce que j'ai vu
sur leboncoin.fr et pour le
non pas dû non pas du tout c'est pour le
livre de laurent baffie le le
dictionnaire c'est il est toujours à
vendre ah ouais ouais ouais et vous
l'avez lu il est bien
d'accord et est ce possible de baisser
le prix de le baisser à 1 euro ou pas
bon bah c'est gentil mais je vais vous
le prendre alors tendez jeu juste avant
les premières
qu'on a la plaisir mais
attendez je joue je vous passe l'auteur
du livre je crois que c'est là quelque
chose à vous dire bonjour monsieur
bonjour pourquoi vous le vendez ce livre
il est formidable pour laisser dans les
toilettes oui j'ai trois cartons de
savons comment ça se fait que vous avez
trois cartons bah en fait t'es pas que
je suis le foot locker du coup les
vagins
j'ai pas reconnu d'avoir ouais
ouais
benjamin dessus
alors là on nous a dit ce jour-là compte
7 tu jouais dans toc toc ce que je ne
savais pas on connaissait tous toc toc
évidemment cette histoire de six
patients victimes de troubles
obsessionnels compulsifs des toc qui est
à attendre dans une salle datant d'être
reçus par un grand spécialiste qui vient
que très rarement en france gros succès
toc toc un énorme succès mondial est
longue et que c'est madame en
[Applaudissements]
zinc
en argentine et en espagne c'est
considéré comme une super pièces et tous
les gens croient que l'auteur est un
intello et tout est laurent a dit ils ne
savent pas que je suis un voyou qui
faisait des caméras cachées
alors benjamin on va te regarder dans
toc toc de laurent baffie
[Musique]
j'ai 22 ans et
il ne fait pas chaud bon à partir de
manon défonce de s'interrompt accord oui
sauf très bien sûr qui ne fait pas
exprès donc ma bagnole g20 besoin je
suis concepteur de jeux vidéo et je
souffre de toc depuis l'adolescence les
plus importants sont la capacité totale
à marcher sur les lignes et ma
fascination pour la symétrie qui sait
quoi faire pourquoi parce que c'est la
couleur qui nous met en ciel
benjamin
becker
[Applaudissements]
chaque année l'école des fans et tes
parents sont dans la salle benjamin
oui oui mais la maison est plus
tranquille à quoi du monde il des shows
live à la
mesa pas dû être facile pour toi te
faire respecter par tes enfants mais
c'est quand canton fonds de commerce et
d'économie à la télé les moules qu'est
ce que tu veux avoir comme autorité sur
eux non mais il ya une façon de les
tenir jeu comme un père autoritaire et
quand il voit toutes les semaines qui a
l'argent de poche qui tombent ils savent
qui est le patron ah c'est vrai que
c'est difficile pour donner l'exemple
quand on est là on l'a dit c'est
difficile parfois
aller à l'école et parce qu'ils
entendent des phrases à la maison qui ne
sont pas des phrases de la vraie vie un
peu plus dur à l'école c'est quand tu
veux faire le con avec tes potes que tu
veux faire n'importe quoi comme tous les
jeunes et que les profs de 10 mais tu te
croit tout permis parce que tu es le
fils de bafia juste envie de faire le
con avec avec vous comme les autres le
petit qui s'appelle bastien époque où il
avait 4 ans un jour la maîtresse fidji
il est où ton cahier il répond dans ton
cul donc
c'est un truc qu'il avait entendu à la
maison ça alors tu as arrêté les études
à 16 ans pourquoi parce que j'avais
envie de j'étais parti une fois l'âge de
10-11 ans avec ma mère aux écuries
pascal montage pâle ouais je détestais
ça ça me plaisait pas du tout et j'étais
parti pour lui faire plaisir et j'ai vu
des gens qui faisaient ou saut
d'obstacles avec l'équipe de france qui
venait s'entraîner à l'endroit où
j'étais et ça m'a donné envie de faire
ça et je me suis déjà heureux de faire
ça ces élus cavaliers comme maman j'ai
fait ce que je championnat de france ah
ouais
[Applaudissements]
donc aller au cours de l'été habitacle
là en fait due justement quand j'étais à
prince était cavalier était payée par un
un gars pour monter les chevaux et
j'étais pas du tout heureux je
n'arrivais plus et puis un jour mon
frère est venu me voir il m'a dit mais
pourquoi tu fais pas du théâtre moi je
toujours dans les théâtres depuis que je
suis petit parce que mon père fait plein
de pièces et ça m'a toujours donné un
peu envie et j'ai décidé d'aller aux
cours florent non ça n'a pas forcément
plu et puis après j'ai eu la chance de
parfaire toc toc en fait là le vrai
parcours du combattant il a un agent il
fait des castings beaucoup de casting il
va faire un film la dent dans trois mois
il va aussi travailler sans papa et
comme il est formidable dans le rôle ça
légitimise le piston parce qu'il est il
et il est vraiment excellent donc non
c'est pas compliqué
c'est plus compliqué
si tu prends ton fils et il est à chier
livegen quand même il est formidable
vous allez le voir au toute la gang de
mehdi baala grande colonie toc toc il a
dit peut-être que si mon père avait été
proctologue j'aurais essayé de mettre
des doigt dans le cul
on voit bien d'eux qu'il tient c'est
très clair tant rêve c'est de faire quoi
alors sa vie une baguette magique je
sais pas mais là déjà d'avoir la chance
de pouvoir être sur scène et tout c'est
un truc de malade ouais c'est génial 6
et on travaille on le ressent un salaire
pour faire ça je recevrai je me dis
[ __ ] c'est fou
quand tu le trouves izia le fils de ma
fille et elle a déjà 10 des beaux yeux
non
c'est pas tenter la
jeunesse méditerranéenne fera montre de
mitu
sa fille moi je suis pas encore congard
what i s'est plaint que j'aime les vieux
moi ça paie elle est plus sûre le père
en tous les cas bienvenue au club st
jean et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inler du tube abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus